I got a technical question for you okay
almost everybody that runs for office
has uh oh and you know I'm hoping maybe
you have a different Insight than we do
because we're not in the world you're in
you've been in it for a while
everybody that runs or becomes president
there's stories about women that come
out you've had that Trump's had it you
know Reagan said it how come there's no
stories of Kennedy can I finish my point
Tom like seriously you got everybody
tomboys like this Tom is always like
this he's the famous guy doing that is
that two volts yeah okay so once again
I'll start from the beginning before Tom
kind of had to jump in so why is it that
every candidate that's what we're gonna
do about the time is the Wikipedia we
call him ugly he's not done yet he has
to do three more details until I asked
my questions can I just do it Tom okay
why is it that every man that's run for
office or become a president has had
women from the past that's come up
you've had it uh Trump's had I think one
only from the past obviously I'm being
very sarcastic you got 12. you got you
got we've got Clinton Biden Bush you got
how come there's no woman from Obama's
past Richard Nixon how come there's no
one from Obama Richard Nixon's past
either well back in the days there was
no social media so I'm going more like
50 right so why why is it why it 40
years why is it that Obama there's no
woman from his past or you think he just
didn't have game where you think like
you know because it's really good at
Secrets he's a good looking guy he has a
good shot left-handed yeah I've seen him
make the shot from the Pat from from the
side
is he dead devout of a Christian maybe
it's because his level of Devotion to
since since we're talking about Obama
let me get this off my chest
my disappointment with Obama has nothing
to do with any of this obviously
um it's that he ran as the guy that
people thought was a guy who was in
Boston in 2004.
I was in the arena when he gave the
introduction speech to uh John Kerry
there's no blue America there's no
reason phenomenal speech phenomenal yeah
there's no Black America there's no
vitamins yeah
um I turned to my producer and I said
you know all they said was a bunch of
platitudes but he said him well
this guy's gonna run for president
someday
so Obama decides to run before he even
knew where the bathroom was
and he's at a black church
and he's talking about how much racism
he thinks there is in America and this
is really important he said
the Moses generation referring to the
generation of Martin Luther King has
gotten us quote 90 of the way there
quote he said My Generation he referred
to his generation as the Joshua
generation has to get us an additional
10 and I thought that was reasonable
because there was a fox opinion poll
2002.
eight percent of Americans think that's
a possibility that Elvis is still alive
so you have to write off around 10 of
the American people so what he's really
saying in my opinion is we've gotten to
the point now where MLK's dream of
people
evaluating you based on content of
character with their own skin you've
pretty much been realized yeah he uh was
on 60 Minutes when he was running
he hadn't yet caught up with Hillary but
he was coming otherwise they wouldn't
put him on there and Steve Croft the
correspondent said Senator if you don't
win will it be because of racism
and I'm at home and I said let's see how
he answered this question let's see if
he gets a Victor cred answer along the
lines of what Al Sharpton would say or
Jesse Jackson would say both of whom ran
for president and claim they didn't get
there because of racism
and Obama said no if I don't win it will
be because I've not articulated a vision
that's exactly what I said for him I
said I'm not going to vote for you tax
been regulated Obamacare but good for
you
he won with 53 of the vote he walked on
the Oval Office third week of January
2009 with 70 approval how then all of a
sudden people say you know I want my
taxes raised I I I want Obamacare no
they said at the very least he's going
to put a knife uh fork in the in the
notion that America remains systemically
racist
both blacks and white start race
relations would improve when you walk in
the Oval Office when he left both blacks
and white started got worse because for
eight years he played race card at the
race car at the race card
from the Cambridge Police acted stupidly
to fight his son he looked like Trayvon
to embracing black lives matter to
saying that racism is in America's DNA
to having an A.G Eric Holder who accused
people that wanted voter ID of engaging
in pernicious racism he he had Al
Sharpton in the White House over 70
times he played the race card time and
time and time again that's not the
person that the American people thought
they hired and that's my problem with
him he's made things worse here's the
guy that had every Advantage best uh
prep school in the state of of Hawaii
becomes the president of Harvard Law
review Charmed existence and here he is
playing the race card that's not what
the American people thought they hired
when they when they voted for him in
2008 so far basic question why so so let
me power power and votes he wants to get
black people angry because black people
will go in there like Lemmings and pull
that lever 90 95 of the democratic party
do you think because of social justice
and Equity whatever the hell that means
do you think his eye is it his ideas or
somebody that's put it in his ear
because of some stuff from the past
hurting his leg see do you think it's
him motivated outside he wanted to get
reelected and he knew that if he as
simple as that as simple as that
you think you think Democrats you think
Nancy Pelosi really believes America's
systemically racist I mean do you think
James Clymer really believes that do you
think Obama really believes that BS he
knows it's not true but he also knows he
wants to win elections you don't win
elections by telling black people look
think about crime think about schools
think about jobs no you could win
election this guy over here is a racist
this guy over here uh wants to hold you
back this guy over here wants to oppress
you that's why we got this nonsense
about reparations by the way notice how
Obama hasn't said Jack about reparations
his whole career he'll post them where
is he oh he's been quiet say something
he's been very say something he doesn't
want to get canceled he knows he's going
to get canceled
and he wants to he wants to remain
relevant he hasn't said a damn thing
about this movement towards reparations
even though he's opposed in his whole
career uh and Larry I think where Pat
was going he's made things worse I I I I
agree I think I think playing the race
card the whole time to go in but anyway
what Pat I think was getting into was uh
about the whole the girl any no female
um Scandal or anything like that
recently I mean last podcast we talked
about a Tucker Tucker Carlson no I know
I know where you were going with that
yes
why Tucker Carlson probably I mean one
of the highest streaming looked at
eyeballs right in the in the history of
Twitter X whatever you want to call it
why out of all people at this specific
time would you bring up a man who has
been on on camera multiple times for 25
years stating passing lie detector tests
you know signing affidavits I don't care
about his past this is what I did with
Obama why what do you think the motive
is to come up I mean the guy's not
getting money the guy doesn't look well
at all what's the motive behind going on
on a platform like that and what's the
motive behind Tucker interviewing him or
the guy going on the planet
Tucker's motivation I think he thinks
it's news really I think he thinks it's
a story that the media I think his angle
is the media were aware of this or could
have been aware of this should have been
aware of this but they wanted to protect
Barack Obama and they circled away
against around him the way they did
around Jeremiah Wright remember when
Jeremiah Wright came out yeah okay uh
all of a sudden uh uh the media is not
talking about this until the video came
out with him saying uh KKK United States
then they had to talk about it I'll just
ask you directions so I think I think
that's what Tucker is saying that this
was a a bombshell story he probably
would not have been elected uh if this
had been covered by the media uh and uh
and it's an example of how bias the
media are I think that's what he said
I'll just ask you directly these guys
both kind of you know don't don't say
these guys no no don't do that don't do
that you asked the question don't say
these guys yeah I'm saying you guys ask
the question do I care whether Obama
might be gay do you think Obama's gay
that's I have no idea don't care yeah
what I care about what I said earlier
that he ran promising to be a racial
uniter and divided us and played the
race car time and time again racism is
in America's DNA are you effing kidding
me the first time Gallup asked white
people if they vote for black president
was it was in the 50s and only around 30
said yes now only about four percent
said they wouldn't vote for a black
person so how does how does DNA uh uh
change like that
that's what I'm angry about him for this
he was a fraud he was a fraud on on
racial conciliation a huge fraud on that
the rest of the stuff the tax suspended
regulating I knew that but you don't
walk into the overlap of 70 approval
rating who are you talking about right
now you're talking about Obama Obama
he's a fraud but Larry as much as you're
saying you don't care
there's a huge percentage of the
Republican base that actually believes
this and actually believes that Michelle
Obama isn't actually a man they call her
Big Mike so I know that this is not your
thing I I don't know anybody calls you
that stop by Larry
before I came in four years ago I never
even heard that Michelle Obama was a man
I didn't think that Obama was gay but
I've heard this multiple times hundreds
of times you must have heard this and
what do you say to that what do you say
to the Republican base would think that
Michelle Obama is a freaking man and
Obama's gay if the Republican base
thought that Michelle Obama was every
bit as as graceful as attractive as
Jacqueline Kennedy they still wouldn't
have voted for him because of his policy
so it doesn't matter
it's it's inconsequential I don't know
Larry I think you're skirting this one I
know I'm not
well well but because some people are
saying this like I've and Pat kind of
brought us up but I've been hearing this
too Larry that the reason Tucker brought
this up and had this guy speak is
because and how many times have we heard
it Pat from how many people that knew
something's out Newsom saying he's not
gonna run yeah the Kamala thing is a
possibility but that Michelle Obama is
going to come in and say Hey listen we I
need to save this everybody's all messed
up nobody's really running Joe Biden's
dying in front of him so you think
Tucker's motivation is to is to make
sure that Michelle Obama doesn't become
president they're saying I I didn't say
it what I'm saying is people have been
saying online that this is one of those
okay if she does uh announce that she's
running they're going to have to address
this fact because nobody I've never seen
anybody ask Obama on camera okay hey
just really quick are you gay have you
ever done any gay homosexual activities
never once and they've been silent since
the day that this came out Larry
Sinclair oh Michelle Obama took a flight
to Spain and hung out with with friends
and Brock didn't go with her just saying
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign